bienvenue dans europe hebdo nous sommes
à bruxelles au coeur du parlement
européen et dans cette émission nous
recevrons l'eurodéputée française
marielle de sarnez avec elle nous
évoquons les derniers soubresauts de
l'actualité européenne et nous irons
également au portugal pour voir les
conséquences concrètes de la crise
économique mais d'abord le tour d'europe
avec l'allemagne et son plan de rigueur
sans précédent climat économique
toujours inquiétant en europe où les
plans d'austérité se succèdent
l'allemagne annoncent un plan drastique
de réduction de ses déficits
berlin prévoit 80 milliards d'euros
d'économies d'ici 2014 turbulences aussi
en dehors de la zone euro la hongrie est
dans une situation comparable à la grèce
la petite phrase lâchée par un officiel
hongrois à semer la panique au premier
ministre viktor orban a lui-même reconnu
que son pays était dans une situation
budgétaire graves conséquences si la
monnaie du pays a perdu plus de 5% 24
heures pas de taxe bancaire mondiale les
ministres des finances des 20 pays les
plus industrialisés n'ont pas trouvé
d'accord sur cette mesure destinée à
couvrir les coûts d'un éventuel défaut
de paiement d'une banque
certains pays comme le canada estime que
le poids de cette taxe retombera sur le
dos des contribuables
la france espère un consensus au
prochain g20 à la fin du mois les
diplomaties européennes à l'épreuve
l'union tente de jouer un rôle dans la
crise déclenchée par l'abordage
meurtrier d'une flottille humanitaire
dans les eaux internationales
les 27 pays ont accentué la pression
pour obtenir la levée du blocus
israélien imposé en 2007 après
l'élection du hamas dans la bande de
gaza
les appels se multiplient pour que
l'union dirige l'anc est réclamée par le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu pour faire
la lumière sur la table du 31 mai qui a
fait 9 morts et 57 blessés selon un
dernier bilan
et puis la pologne sur le pied de guerre
une nouvelle alerte a été décrétée à
varsovie avec l'arrivée d'une seconde
vague de crue sur la vistule
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
ont été évacuées dans le sud est où des
digues ont rompu
les inondations ont fait une quinzaine
de morts dans le pays
elle touche aussi la slovaquie et la
hongrie nous avons été rejoints par
marielle de sarnez bonjour alors vous
êtes vice présidente du groupe des
démocrates et des libéraux ici à
bruxelles vous êtes également ici à
bruxelles et à strasbourg vous siégez
depuis dix ans
quand on voit l'allemagne qui annonce un
plan de rigueur d'austérité de 80
milliards d'euros
est ce que ça vous fait peur pour la
croissance en europe témoin il ya deux
choses qui me frappe
la première chose c'est que l'ensemble
des pays en tous les cas une grande
majorité de pays européens annoncent des
plans de rigueur en ce moment ça a
commencé par la grèce portugal l'espagne
la grande bretagne
bientôt la hongrie l'allemagne il y à
quelques heures maintenant
et tout ça se fait chacun chez soi
chacun pour soi sans aucune coordination
alors moi ça fait dix ou quinze ans que
nous disons que nous voulons une
coordination économique
depuis le début de la crise financière
monétaire économique
tout le monde ne cesse de dire
gouvernance économique gouvernement
économique coordination et la zéro
aucune coordination cette date les
réunions se multiplient
il ne cesse de se réunir il ne cesse de
se rencontrer et on a le sentiment que
tout ça reste dans l'ordre du virtuel ça
c'est la première chose qui me frappe
et la deuxième chose qui me frappait les
plus franco française j'ai l'impression
que tous les pays qui nous entourent ce
pas une impression c'est une réalité
sont aujourd'hui dans des économies
extrêmement lourde
est ce que si on gère pas le déficit
aujourd'hui sont des plans de rigueur
dix fois plus lourds qui va falloir
organiser demain et que la france reste
relativement comme isolé au milieu de
cela comme une
où on aurait aucun problème de déficit
de dell
alors qu'on a des sérieux très sérieux
problèmes de déficit en france nicolas
sarkozy a annoncé quand même des
économies pour les années qui viennent
c'est pas suffisant même ordre que ce
qui se passe dans les autres pays
alors je n'imagine pas que ce qui se
passe ailleurs ne pourrait pas se
produire ici on a des déficits
on a une dette extrêmement l'autre donc
nous sommes fragilisés et donc je crois
que moi je préférerais qu'on agisse de
nous même par nous mêmes avant que les
marchés nous l'imposent
et cette absence de coordination convoi
puisque l'allemagne va dans son coin les
autres pays également s'agit pas de
stigmatiser l'allemagne la conséquence
pour ça c'est pas mal surtout que c'est
un sport a ses favoris en france en ce
moment de stigmatiser l'allemagne je
trouve que autant l'allemagne a eu des
problèmes au mans la grèce et angela
merkel a eu à mon avis la mauvaise
réaction mais elle était dans des
problèmes de politique intérieure que je
peux comprendre autant on peut
comprendre aussi qu'il va y revenir à
une
voilà un beau tennis qu'est ce qu'on vit
ce que me passe au cordeau né comme ça
et on risque de ne pas peser et si on
passe passe et les marchés qui décide et
donc c'est exactement ça qu'on a vu avec
la spéculation et avec ce qui s'est
produit sur la grèce si vous n'existez
pas tous ensemble d'abord il peut y
avoir des défauts de solidarité c'est ce
qu'on a vu aussi sur la grèce et puis si
vous n'existez pas parce que les marchés
qui prennent le pas sur la politique est
donc la seule réponse c'est d'agir en
commun
alors on sait que vraisemblablement
cette absence de coordination ça crée
des tensions justement au sein du couple
franco allemand nicolas sarkozy serait
un peu exaspéré justement par le fait
que quand gala merkel prennent ce genre
de décisions seul
vous pensez que ça jouait ce que vous
pensez d'ailleurs que le moteur franco
allemand quand comme on l'appelle est en
panne actuellement je pense qu'il est
vital qu'ils ne soient pas en panne mais
les donc je pense qu'il faut tout faire
pour qu'il ne soit pas en panne mais les
j'espère que et nicolas sarkozy et
angela merkel vont voir savoir
comprendre et montrer à l'union
européenne toute entière que ils sont
ensemble
c'est absolument vital ce sommet a été
reportée ils vont se voir je crois dans
quelques jours pour préparer le prochain
conseil et puis ensuite le g20
on a besoin d'une europe qui agit c qui
pèsent ensemble mais on a besoin aussi
de sortir des discours c'est à dire
qu'on a besoin de rentrer vraiment dans
la coordination et on devrait avoir une
sorte de pilotage commun des efforts qui
vont être nécessaires dans l'ensemble
les états membres pour revenir à l
équilibre tout simplement
alors le pilotage commun la gouvernance
économique c'est ce qu'essaye de faire
les états européens les ministres des
finances européens étaient réunis à
luxembourg et ils ont annoncé plusieurs
décisions importantes
regardez
440 milliards d'euros c'est le montant
du plan d'urgence
enfin activé un mois après son adoption
basée au luxembourg ce fonds de garantie
pourra emprunter sur les marchés et
accorder des prêts à des états
incapables de trouver de l'argent frais
aujourd'hui la grèce demain peut-être le
portugal ou l'espagne
en contrepartie la discipline budgétaire
est renforcée dans la zone euro les pays
qui laisseraient filer leurs déficits et
leurs dettes seront plus durement
sanctionnés
nous allons améliorer le pacte de
stabilité en créant davantage de
sanctions intervenant plus tôt
les sanctions pourraient être mises en
place même si la limite actuelle de 3%
du pib pour les déficits publics n'est
pas dépassée par exemple ou si les mises
en garde ne sont pas pris en compte par
les pays
les ministres ont aussi accepté que la
commission européenne examine dans les
grandes lignes les budgets des pays de
la zone euro avant leur passage devant
les parlements nationaux
cet arsenal de mesures constituent la
première pierre du gouvernement
économique que certains en europe
appellent de leurs voeux
c'est aussi une arme lourde destiné à
rassurer les marchés alors que l'euro
continue de baisser
s'approchant de son cours d'introduction
en 1999 à 1,18 dollar
alors le contrôle des budgets nationaux
au préalable par bruxelles et par les
autres pays européens marielle de sarnez
de l'ensemble des budgets je trouve que
c'est une bonne chose il faut de la
coordination budgétaire on a une union
monétaire et on a pas de coordination
budgétaire donc évidemment si bancal et
on peut pas avoir une union monétaire
et ils n'y ont budgété à si elles
existent demain sans une loi économique
se sera donc il va falloir qu'on a
évidemment plus loin oui ça je n'ai pas
de rogner les prérogatives du parlement
mais il s'agit de regarder dans les
grandes masses budgétaires ainsi les
équilibres en mcad finances publiques
sont respectés et c'est nécessaire sans
ça ça plombe un pays on peut pas vivre
durablement à crédit et deuxièmement il
s'agit de dégager des marges de
manoeuvre pour préparer l'avenir et pour
investir et écoutez c'est mieux de le
faire à plusieurs que tout seul dans son
coin est ce que vous êtes là vous
rapaces qui éventuellement un feu rouge
carton rouge qu'il soit donné si le
budget qui est présenté ne convient pas
je suis favorable au feu orange ça y est
je suis favorable qu'effectivement on
puisse agir avant d'être dans la
catastrophe bien qu'on puisse faire de
la prévention
intelligente et efficace ce qui est
malheureusement beaucoup trop rares et
en france et en europe
un mot quand même sur gaza on l'a vu
tout à l'heure l'europe a tenté de
réagir là encore de façon peut-être un
petit peu coordonnée sur ce qui s'est
passé au large de gaza et que la
flottille
est-ce que vous pensez que maintenant ça
y est c'est géant veut dire c'est c'est
oublier finalement n'en a pas tiré les
leçons
écoutez je pense que l'europe ne pèse
pas sur ce dossier tellement lourd du
proche orient qui a des résonances
évidemment universel au delà même de la
région du proche orient
je pense qu'il faut que l'union
européenne se décide à exister et à dire
un certain nombre de choses sont
notamment le plan de paix pour cette
région qu effectivement il faut lever le
blocus mais qu'il faut en même temps et
en face garantir une sécurité à israël
qui est aussi son droit notamment avec
toute la question de l'iran donc on
pourrait très bien imaginer par exemple
en méditerranée une force
d'interposition interposition européenne
pourquoi pas mais en tous les cas israël
a droit à la sécurité et les
palestiniens ont droit à un avenir
est ce que madame ashton qui est la voix
de l'europe en matière de politique
étrangère a été suffisamment présente
non mais en même temps je suppose qu'on
peut pas lui demander de tout régler à
la place de tout le monde
la vérité c'est qu'on a besoin d'une
europe forte et cette europe forte c'est
pas seulement les institutions
européennes ça doit être les 27 états
membres
si les 27 états membres ne sont pas
capables de s'entendre sur une cohérence
de politique vis-à-vis du proche orient
on ne posera jamais là-bas merci
beaucoup de sarnez d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
on va repartir dans la crise économique
européenne voir quelles sont ses
conséquences sur le terrain avec kathia
gilder et un reportage au portugal oui
nous sommes allés à lisbonne pour voir
quelle était la réalité sur place loin
des marchés financiers alors le pays
est-il en difficulté y at il un vrai
risque d'explosion sociale au portugal
yoann cela est allé prendre le pouls de
la population
regardez son reportage
elle est de loin la salle des marchés la
plus connue des habitants du centre de
lisbonne la grande zoa de ribera et ses
petits commerces loin
très loin des traders des agences de
notation et des places financières en
plein doute
et pourtant depuis quelques semaines à
l'image du reste du pays
au coeur d'une inquiétante crise
économique qui n'épargne vraiment
personne
elles n'ont acquis nous quatre en ce
moment ça se passe de plus en plus mal
même en travaillant de nuit en gagne
trois fois rien après 20 ans 30 ans ici
il ya beaucoup de collègues qui ferment
tout le monde s'en va
dans time le plus dur c'est payer les
factures et avec ces réformes je ne suis
vraiment pas sûr que ça gênait pas
d'argent optoma ça devient de plus en
plus profitable de vivre ici
4 à son image floue si aujourd'hui les
rues de la ville ont retrouvé leur calme
elle porte encore les traces de la
mobilisation des dernières semaines
après athènes et madrid le 29 mai
dernier
yg lisbonne s'est embrasée trois cent
mille personnes venues de tout le pays
une affluence record pour dénoncer les
mesures de rigueur mises en place dans
l'urgence par le gouvernement socialiste
un remède de cheval pour réduire les
déficits publics et retrouver les
faveurs des banques
pas vraiment du goût des responsables de
la cgtp le plus gros syndicat du pays
mais nous ces mesures vont se traduire
par le gel des salaires et des retraites
et surtout par des réductions des aides
sociales comme les allocations chômage
et tout ça alors que le nombre de
chômeurs n'a jamais été aussi haut ces
trente dernières années cette politique
met en danger notre futur et si on
laisse faire la demande intérieure
continuera de chuter et les problèmes
eux continueront d'empirer
e
mon bonheur
l'accord de blain
dans la capitale du fado les victimes de
la crise loges pour la plupart de
l'autre côté du tage là où les loyers
sont beaucoup moins chères quartiers
populaires d'almada c'est ici que josé
lien 67 ans ancien employé de
l'industrie textile a élu domicile ici
qu'elle est confrontée aux mêmes
problèmes que la plupart des retraités
du pays
les fins de mois difficiles avant les
enfants des retraités étaient là pour
donner un coup de pouce mais avec la
baisse des salaires ces dernières années
on est doublement touché moins de
retraite et moins d'être familiale
dizaine de voisins qui l'a même pas à
payer leurs médicaments
elle compte d une prescription ils sont
obligés de choisir les plus importants à
la pharmacie l'énergie la chance d'être
en bonne santé
370 euros de retraite moyenne et une
sécurité sociale insuffisante pour
couvrir les besoins des plus âgés et
pour les plus jeunes un smic à moins de
500 euros et un taux de chômage de plus
de 12%
il y à 12 ans pedro matos né français de
parents portugais a fait le choix de
venir s'installer ici
à l'époque le pays semblait bien parti
pour rattraper ses voisins européens
aujourd'hui le jeune homme travaille
dans un centre d'appels pour un peu plus
de 700 euros par mois
la promesse d'une vie meilleure aura été
de courte durée
c'est très très rare qu'à la fin du mois
moi avec mon argent j'ai du mal à voir
par exemple je ne sais pas moi 50 euros
des fois même pas et parce que je gagne
750 euros alors imaginez les personnes
qui gagnent 500 les jeunes de mon âge
envie de partir il y en a par exemple
qui ne sont jamais sortis du pays et ils
ont envie de tenter leur chance
moi même je pense repartir à l'étranger
comme ses parents il y à plus de 40 ans
pedro envisage à son tour de faire ses
adieux à lisbonne cette fois ci pourtant
au portugal le scénario d'un envol
massif de la jeune génération reste très
improbable dans une europe elle aussi en
crise les destinations sont de plus en
plus rares
voilà pour ces images tournées à
lisbonne et ce reportage de yohan mahé
caroline tavares nous sommes toujours à
bruxelles avec deux invités de députée
européenne avec regina bastos bonjour
vous êtes députée européenne portugaise
du groupe ppe est lui au portugal sous
les couleurs du parti social démocrate
est à vos côtés votre collègue espagnol
et des regards diaf à bâle c'est comme
ça qu'on dit je pense du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates alors vous
représentez deux pays du sud qui sont
particulièrement attaquées par les
marchés on a essayé de comprendre quelle
était la réalité de ces pays notamment
au portugal là on a vu un peu le tableau
noir puisque on a essayé d'aller à la
rencontre de ceux qui sont directement
touchés par la crise
vous qui êtes députée portugaise
quelles sont les raisons d'espérer
les troupes styliste pour l'avenir de ce
pays nous sommes vraiment face à une
crise et nous avons un problème et nous
avons besoin de trouver des solutions
pour cette problème nous sommes un
peuple je pense optimiste par
conformiste et on doit déjà envisagé
cette crise avec espérance histoire dans
le futur donc ce reportage tourné par
johan relais et fidèles pour vous à la
réalité qu'il y a un problème les
personnes les familles les citoyens
portugais ont un problème maintenant il
y avait un taux de chômage très très
problématique
on a un problème de croissance
économique
et on a aussi des raisons pour être
optimiste je pense que c'est qu'elle les
au portugal nous donne au portugal
comment à l'europe ne donne la notion de
qu' on n'a plus besoin de plus
d'intégration plus d'europe
c'est pas une crise c'est ça la solution
pour vous à sept jours à ce qu'il passe
pour plus d'intégration plus de
coordination plus de surveillance dans
un nouveau plus haut plus d'intégration
économique pour les tic en toute
l'europe en tous les états membres
alors vous a aidé à garder la balle qui
est espagnol comment vous voyez la
situation dans ce pays voisin
et surtout est ce qu'il y a des éléments
de comparaison possible entre l'espagne
et le portugal
oui mais en fait un art de comparer
l'espagne avec le portugal mais aussi
l'on peut le comparer avec la france ou
avec l'allemagne avec l'angleterre
malheureusement ce ne sont pas nos deux
pays qui sont en crise c'est tout le
monde et spécialement l'europe donc on
peut voir beaucoup de
deux choses similaires dans tous les
pays de l'europe et d'ailleurs dans ces
derniers jours et dans ces dernières
semaines on voit que tous les pays de
l'europe sont en train de prendre les
mêmes mesures pour essayer de mettre les
d'accord avec votre collègue il faut une
coordination davantage de coordination
entre tous les pays européens
oui tout à fait parce que nous ne vivons
pas dans l'amp est seul nous sommes dans
une robe unie nous avons un marché
commun nous avons une même monnaie mais
même avec les états unis ou avec
d'autres pays du monde
nous nous vivons dans un monde
complètement globalisé il faut
comprendre tous les mêmes mesures
il faut qu'on travaille tous ensemble
alors il ya quand même des tensions
sociales je pense que c'est la question
la question c'est que nous sommes un
club des 27 pays que ça me sentais créé
dans un monde global nous avons une
crise globale
donc on a besoin d'avoir on a nécessité
d'avoir des réponses globales et cette
réponse passe pour une coordination des
politiques budgétaires des politiques
économiques
parce que nous avons des objectifs qui
on doit achever ensemble alors justement
je propose d'écouter les doléances des
syndicats portugais
une représentante de l'ain de la cgtp
l'un des principal
les principaux syndicats du pays à une
question directe à vous poser écouter
what kind of measures quel type de
mesures allez-vous mettre en oeuvre
remédier à cette situation dans les pays
européens et surtout non pour tenir les
promesses que la plupart des hommes
politiques en place ont fait aux
populations européennes et en
particulier aux travailleurs pour que le
scénario qui a conduit à cette crise ne
se répète plus jamais ni beat again
alors est ce qu est ce qu un député
européen que vous êtes peut répondre à
l'appel d'un citoyen de son pays
je pense que cette problème de qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour éviter d autres
crises c'est un problème quand on doit
avoir solution donc on doit anticiper
les crises et pour anticiper les crises
nous avons besoin d'avoir plus surfer
ans
on doit avoir la coordination je pense
que 7e jeu doit cesser dans sept mots
plus surveillance pour éviter les crises
on doit avoir des coordination
économique pour avoir de croissance
d'emploi et de de dermo nisation de
toutes les politiques économiques et et
pour achever en croissance et pour
éviter le chômage
en attendant mais en attendant c'est
quand même des populations qui souffrent
directement des centaines et des
milliers de personnes crient descendant
dans les rues au portugal comme en
espagne est ce qu'il ya des risques
ce que vous redoutez en espagne par
exemple une explosion sociale dans le
pays et voir même des émeutes comme
celles qui ont eu lieu récemment en
grèce
je ne crois pas
je crois que les citoyens espagnols ils
sont très conscients d'un moment quand
nous vivants et ils sont assez solidaire
avec parce que le bcc les citoyens et
c'est vrai que c'est difficile c'est
vrai qu'aucun gouvernement veut prendre
ces mesures aucun gouvernement veut dire
à ses citoyens
on ne peut plus faire des dépenses ici
ou là dans le gouvernement zapatero n'a
pas eu peur de de mener ses réformes à
marche forcée glisser l'air chose qui
n'est pas du tout facile pour un
gouvernement ce n'est pas facile de dire
à ses citoyens
écoutez il faut qu'on fasse des
économies je ne peux plus mettre tout
l'argent que je voulais dans des
investissements ou pour les pour les
nouveaux nés par exemple ce n'est pas
quelque chose de facile mais je crois
que les gens et sont conscients et ils
sont solidaires de la situation que nous
vivons est ce que vous ne pensez pas qu
au portugal ce sont finalement les des
plus pauvres et ceux qui sont déjà dans
la crise qui risque de payer la facture
de la réforme menée par le premier
ministre socrates ch/le je pense que les
citoyens
c'est une les citoyens ne peuvent pas
être pénalisés deux fois il y à des
gouvernements dans l'europe qui ont pris
des mauvaises mesures politiques
économiques
ils les citoyens ont payé pour cette
mauvaise mesure maintenant ils payent
aussi pour les mesures de rigueur donc
je pense que la sanction sur les
citoyens
c'est pas le chemin correct on doit
avoir des responsabilités politiques
mais aussi de solidarité
je pense que la solidarité eau au coeur
de l'europe vient en viande
viens aux rencontres de ce qu a dit
schumann l'europe se fait avec
solidarité avec des des mesures
concrètes et petit à petit maintenant
nous avons un problème dans la zone euro
nous avons un problème que c'est pas
seulement du portugal seulement
d'espagne mais on a des pays plus
faibles du sud europe la grèce l'irlande
l'italie aussi le portugal l'espagne
donc c'est un problème de tous leurs
biens
et c'est un problème global à l'anc on a
besoin d'avoir la conscience quand on a
un modèle social européen qui fait la
différence
en face des autres modèles du monde
d'anthony mondiale doit l'obligation de
le soutenir
et ça se fait avec solidarité il y avait
cru ce pensable on a compris votre
message
en attendant qu en fait quand même des
politiques de rigueur qui se mettent en
place un peu partout en europe en
quelques mots pour terminer cette
émission est ce que vous pensez pas qu
un tel virage de rigueur ne risque pas
de tuer le peu de croissance qui
viendront de se manifester en europe
mais j'espère que ça ne soit pas le cas
parce que c'est vrai que dans un premier
moment la politique de l'europe en
général et terme plan de relance
maintenant l'économie apparemment pour
les données qu'on a commencent à sortir
un peu de la crise mais c'est vrai que
arrêter complètement ce plan de relance
et ses investissements
un plan pour réduire le déficit ces
brusques c'est un peu risqué c'est vrai
que la croissance soit un peu plus
tranquille
mais c'est vrai que c'est nécessaire de
le faire parce qu'on a vu que les
marchés financiers sinon vents s'avère
l'euro et c'est ce qu'on essaye de
délation et solidarité merci à vous
d'avoir été sur ce plateau d'europe et
d'eau pour commenter cette crise que
l'on va continuer de traiter
on va dans les médias se quitter avec
notre coup d'oeil culturel on a repéré
cette semaine un festival nova rock
un rendez vous incontournable en europe
pour les amateurs de heavy metal et de
hard rock il a lieu chaque année depuis
cinq ans en autriche petit avant goût en
images et en musique
je dis non
ch
voilà des images du festival nova rock
qui se tient du 11 au 13 juin en
autriche
c'est la fin de cette émission la
semaine prochaine europe hebdo sera à
strasbourg d'ici là bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
les